way.i I remember sighs when I was a bad
rise of the in prefix I'm gonna plays I
can be spider-man or renegade spider-man
someone suggesting a review on Marvel
Ultimate Alliance ah it's funny you say
that because um yeah it's funny you say
that
do you like the [ __ ] [ __ ] spider-man
couldn't lift that I'm sure if he had
time he was better man super strong you
can lift a tank you can lift a train I'm
not like referencing the movie I mean he
can actually lift a train like a whole
train car and then hit someone with it I
didn't like gantry much either George I
thought he was I didn't think he was all
that great I feel like if you pretend
he's not spider-man he's really cool
yeah that's totally fair assessment
actually Wow I'll give me the top man
top five spiders spider boys are you
[ __ ] ring out this is Russell take
that guy who's vaguely resembles electro
I can't get me I just wanted better
bread you know that one is a - button
holy cow this is the - button but look
at how far I - I got my - yeah that's
what happens when I my favorite thing
yellow web stops you just stop it's
weird how this game predicted the Sam
Raimi black suit spider-man costume but
just slightly different like it's yellow
but still lately it's pretty close
someone asked which state do we live in
we live in weed we live in the state of
depression we live State what's up super
tough now I can't run away from anything
except I was shooting laser webs they're
yellow I'm golden shower spider-man or I
shoot yellow we're not suck I beat you
just by standing in the middle of the
year right now what do you mean one life
left [ __ ] you yeah dramatically
this is so unreasonable like you what
button have you been mashing you think
I'm throwing okay if you hold the right
truck the right trigger and then hit one
of the face buttons it does like a
special move so yeah see
it's ranged attacks I'm lightning boy
and I'm kicking you in the face
okay I'm that's my power I'm the
spectacular kicking you in the face man
Xavier and I have this conversation on a
daily basis when we were little we
thought shut the Shadow the Hedgehog
game was so edgy just because like what
in the open yeah in the opening scene
you shoot a bunch of cops with an Uzi
and then you hear him say dammit dammit
and he's standing next to Sonic it's
like oh my god
they said damn it so hardcore reasonable
foreigners are dirty
yeah it's true um what um stop this are
the game I'm actually good at every
button out I literally pressed every
button possible it wants to make that
happen
this is how I've beaten all the bosses
so far is just throwing things on at
them and then going rage mode I can't
pick up that truck that you can pick up
it's because I'm tough is it I haven't
taken a single life up your lifespan I
want to die
ow why are you being real okay I'm
colorblind so I didn't even realize she
was green I knew though the Lightning
was yellow but it's like it's not it's
scream are you serious
mmm damn it I hate venom plenty of times
mr. Kruger pool
you just didn't die I brought his health
down to half like twice but other than
that you know what Hecky you know [ __ ]
the skin you're very upset come on play
something else plenty I hear ya I have
so many games why are you but [ __ ]
Josh asks Moon Knight um well it's first
off it's an honour Moon Knight it's an
honor
thanks moon knight for writing in second
off the answer to that [ __ ] you is uh
because II um didn't the Photoshop me a
new logo a year ago i I will rain
vengeance on you Josh thanks mr. moon
night again I really appreciate it
alright we're streaming it was exactly
two hundred oh no let's do it we've got
exactly two hundred viewers watching
this is the perfect so much nudity
there yeah by the way is the ultimate
edition so I have all the DLC characters
too and the costumes I think you don't
have just injustice too don't you I do
not have injustice too because I'm very
poor and I can't afford it no you guys
sign is seen you without saving do you
think what Joe okay go do the Joker and
justice too is actually a lot of fun
doesn't he have wait now I'm thinking of
uh I don't play high tier I'm thinking
of mine I don't know who to play there's
so many characters and plus like DLC hey
Xavier its Jacob do you have any advice
for me and Duck Duck YouTube for a first
year high school uh oh yeah Jacob it's a
costume man who does all those sick ass
cosplays on Twitter I don't know if he
wants me to say his last name unless the
tennis is username nah but Jacobs an
awesome guy and so is duck duck they're
both very young just starting high
school I would tell you it just this can
be really bad advice like
someone donated $10 someone donated $10
thank you they say [ __ ] they said oh
your pork take some money thank you
you know what's funny is when I research
for videos like I always try to find
like Google Image Search of random
photos of comic book characters it is so
easy to accidentally click through like
three things and find porn I don't know
if I want to necessarily tell what
college I'm going to no yes no that was
a joke don't do that because they don't
know he's just look it up and then go
there I don't want I don't ever want to
be in that situation that PewDiePie was
in where just someone just walked into
his front door and was like hey I forgot
how to play this game by the way so you
might actually have an edge oh I'm
really bad at this quarter sure I can do
this really reliably wait a second BRB
gonna go watch some hentai have fun guy
okay all right have a good time I guess
all right what Xavier senpai [ __ ] you in
the ass for 100 billion dollars probably
not oh okay so for a future reference
lay add button I could just click play
that like I just play this series I
actually have no idea how that works
okay press it just okay it happens I
don't like mr. Dan Slott very much I
think he's a mean guy dark I had an
argument with him on Twitter once and I
won
[Music]
you guys ever watch uh what was it
Action League now there was a character
named the flesh and his powers he was
just a naked strong guy I need I think
there was a guy who was a dinky diver
and his power was just that he lived in
a toilet that's pretty dumb actually
remember that fan theory on Twitter
where everyone who was trying to say
that Peter Parker is a trans boy in life
yeah their reasoning was like well he's
a 15 year old boy and he can't tie a tie
because it's his first dance as a boy I
was like I don't know how to tie a tie I
don't think I could find a single person
who knows how to tie a tie I could talk
to so many people that would have no
idea how to tie a tie lost lots of
teenagers they're not a tie at times do
you know how both of us are amongst
those high up dad get my dad to do it so
one time we were like a random
restaurant I can't remember which one it
was he was like Chili's or [ __ ]
Village Inn or something but we were at
a restaurant and someone there was just
so drunk that they threw up all over the
front like right up where are you or
like oh I asked to get a table and it
was just everywhere right and I felt so
bad for like the waitresses who had to
like go out of their way to clean it up
so like I was just sitting like seeing
them like struggle and look all sad all
night trying to deal deal with it so I
went over and just like gave them each
ten bucks just because I had like some
extra I think it was after a birthday so
I just had some money from birthday
cards like waiting around in my wallet I
was just like hey I know you guys have
had a shitty night so here you go
and even though it was only ten bucks
they both started like crying
okay so I worked at a Halloween store
during October last year it was just
like a seasonal job like you work here
for like 34 days and that's it it was I
think it was actually like my first
official job and it sucks so bad because
I was working more hours than anyone
else and I almost like failed one of my
classes because I was doing like so much
like cuz we that was right around the
time that my parents split up so we were
having like crazy money problems so I
was like they're like what days are you
available and I said uh after school
from 4:00 to 10:00 right and I was like
I don't want to work every day of the
week and they're like no don't worry you
won't so then after a couple people quit
because they hated the manager so much I
ended up working five days a week on it
actually no six days a week I worked six
days a week for like two two and a half
weeks
uh-hum because I was the only one who's
had like enough hours listed like they
kind of just took advantage of what I
wrote down so yeah I and just so many
people are really shitty like you don't
have the same kind of etiquette in a
Halloween store that you would in like a
Walmart or something if someone's you
know like they're not they don't treat
the employees with any kind of respect
there is this lady who like bought a
costume then ripped it then tried to get
it returned and then brought it back and
was like hey I want to return this or
replace it and we're like you can't do
that yeah there's a no return policy you
tell me you mean she just started
yelling at us right in like making a
giant scene at the front of the store
and she's like some like 50-something
year-old lady and it was it was really
bad because she started like getting
like really hot and bothered and mad
about it and like throwing things almost
and we were like okay okay how about
this because the zipper on this one is
broken God knows how we're not blaming
you
we'll go get another one and you could
just exchange it and then we'll take
this one and then throw it away I guess
right because we were that upset because
she had been yelling at
for like 20 minutes and our manager
wasn't there that day so eventually we
just kind of settled on like okay we'll
get you the new one and then we handed
it to her and she's like well I don't
want that one I want a different one
it's like you can't exchange it for a
not identical thing like you bought a
bee costume you should keep the bee
costume right she's like no I want this
this uh I think it was like a wow we're
getting a lot of messages I think I
think she likes switched it out for like
a princess costume and she's like too
old to wear either of these honestly
like she would have looked really silly
and either of them because they were
kind of revealing and she was like like
I can't that she was like a female Ned
Flanders if I had to come up with like
something like a mental image for this
and uh you know she's like I don't want
this one we're like well we don't know
how to help you then and she was like
I'm going to the other competitor
Halloween store down the road
Oh god.what alone oh we're so sad we lot
like you already bought the costume once
we didn't lose your sale sorry and then
and then if she was like I'm never
coming back here again and this is great
cuz my my boss cuz there's like the
manager and then like the sub manager I
guess like the person under them it was
great cuz she heard me say this but as
she was like I'm never coming back here
again I went good it was loud enough
that my boss could hear it but not the
lady walking away and then my boss was
like come on dude
I have one other funny story from the
Halloween store go for it okay so there
is this dad who brought in his like
three year old and it was just the two
of them right and he he brought the kid
over and was like they were looking
through costumes and this three-year-old
little kid found this Wolverine costume
and he was just so excited like he tried
it on in the store there we had the
changing room and he put it on and he
walked out with it he's like can he can
he wear it out of the store I was like
yeah totally and he was just this most
adorable little kid going
I'm so excited like he was shaking he
was so happy and I was like that made my
day I hope nothing bad happens
immediately after then into in comes two
kids already in Halloween costumes one
of them was like 13 the other was maybe
like 11 or 12 and one of them was in a
Master Chief costume and the other was
in a Donald Trump costume and they had
no parents and they were by themselves
and reminds me of me and they were just
they walked in hold on wait no don't I
didn't want to do that
but I'll get back to my story about
Donald Trump and Master Chief walking
into the store so he's two kids um like
I don't know where their parents were or
where they had come from there was like
an apartment complex right next to the
Halloween store so I could only assume
they lived there and just walked over
cuz one of them didn't even have shoes
on like he was in his socks in a Donald
Trump costume and and he's like there
are two little Mexican kids but one of
them had on a blonde wig so I I don't I
I guess he was memeing if that's the
term but uh they walk in and immediately
just start taking [ __ ] off the shelves
and then just putting it on the floor or
like throwing things or like pulling
things out of the packaging or they kept
asking me all kinds of dumb questions or
like hey is that tattoo real yeah yeah
no it's not this is a temporary I
actually got a sticker from the store
down the yeah I got this Deadpool stick
with this stick this circular Deadpool
stick around
wait are you playing as Deathstroke
[Music]
she should be like that okay anyway back
to talking about Master Chief and Donald
Trump tearing up the Halloween store so
after they had asked me a bunch of
really weird - noxious questions and
like because I was trying to mop up the
place but they kept throwing things on
the ground like like little things like
it was annoying like one of them had
candy in his pocket and was just
shoveling it into his face and leaving
[ __ ] wrappers all over the store and
I had to ah I really hated that but like
every time I tried to tell the manager
like hey these kids are kind of being
[ __ ] over here can you like kick
them out because they're not buying
anything and they're just ripping up the
place and he was it was only the two of
us working that day because again the
Wow that was effective uh you know it
just it wasn't ran properly that store
was a giant [ __ ] the entire time
so he was like manning the register and
there were so many people in that day
that he couldn't really do anything
about it
so these kids got back into like the
back section of the store where like the
more adult costumes are and I was like
oh god because then they got ahold of
like the zentai suits so one of them
ripped off his master chief costume then
left it on the floor like he didn't even
change in the changing room he just
changed out in the middle of the place
and then put on this Slender Man costume
and it was so ill-fitting because it was
like made for someone like half his size
that he ended up breaking it like it
ripped in like three places and we had
to throw it away and then the other one
found this like joke costume that was
like a naked hillbilly with his genitals
blurred out and he put that on but over
his Donald Trump costume and like they
were like he went to go put it on in the
the changing room like he actually used
it and he was like hey here man help me
put a zip it up in the back and because
the other one had a Slender Man costume
on it had these like long fingers that
were like like you know just hanging
there with like filled with like foam or
something so he couldn't do it right and
then zipped up his hair in it and then
they got into a fistfight almost knocked
out one of the walls
the changing room and then they okay the
one dressed is a naked hillbilly uh
ended up running all over the place and
then wiped out super hard and hurt
himself because he was like I mean he
didn't have shoes and he was in his
zentai and then slipped on the tiles and
bang his head and he ran over and almost
tackled the little Wolverine from
earlier like that little three year old
boy who was super excited because he was
Wolverine I was just so [ __ ] angry at
that point does that little Wolverine
was like the best thing that happened
that day cuz he was so excited and he
was so happy units all hopping up and
down this little bastard and Donald
Trump costume almost hurt him like I
actually just like my manager was on the
exact other side of the store so I got
away with it so I just started like like
yelling at them and told them to I
actually told them to get the hell out I
didn't want to say [ __ ] that would have
been too far I told them to get the hell
out and then they went and put on their
original costumes and then left and I
had to clean up everything that they
were they destroyed no I retail retail
jobs sauce
[Music]
[Music]